I think you're going to find this clip
interesting. Republican Chris Christie, former
Jersey governor, big Trump supporter, said over
the weekend that Donald Trump's legal challenges,
which, of course, are bogus, that's me saying it,
not Chris, have become a national embarrassment,
says Chris Christie. Christie previously said,
I think it was very late on election night.
If Trump has evidence of fraud, he should
be given the opportunity to present it.
Christie now says he's been given the opportunity.
He's not presented it. And this is now becoming an
embarrassment. Take a look at this horse.
After President Trump's speech on
early Wednesday morning, the day after the
election, you said it's incumbent on him
to come forward with the evidence. They've now
been thirty four court cases the president has
lost. We saw Pennsylvania last night. We saw
Pat Toomey, the senator from Pennsylvania, say
it's time for the president to enable this
transition. It's time for the president to concede
the president's response was to attack Pat Toomey
on Twitter. Is it finally time for this to end?
Yes, and here's the reason why the president
has had an opportunity to access the courts and
I said to you, you know, George, starting
at 2:00, 3:00 a.m. on Wednesday morning,
if you've got the evidence of fraud presented
and what's happened here is, quite frankly,
the conflict, the president's legal team
has been a national embarrassment. Cindy
Powell accusing Governor Brian Camp of a crime
on television, yet being unwilling to go on TV
and defend and lay out the evidence that she
supposedly has. This is outrageous. Covic by
any lawyer and noticed George, they won't do
it inside the courtroom. They allege fraud
outside the courtroom. But when they go inside the
courtroom, they don't plead fraud and they don't
argue fraud. This is what I was concerned about at
two 30 in the morning on Wednesday night. Listen,
I've been a supporter of the president's.
I voted for him twice, but elections have
consequences and we cannot continue to act as
if something happened here that didn't happen.
You have an obligation to present the evidence.
The evidence has not been presented. And you must
conclude, as Tucker Carlson even concluded the
other night, that if you're unwilling to come
forward to present the evidence, it must mean
the evidence doesn't exist. That's what I was
concerned about starting on election night, and
I remain concerned today. I think it's wrong. I
think what you've heard lots of Republicans
starting to say this. I said it on election
night and I hope more safe going forward because
the country is what has to matter the most. As
much as I'm a strong Republican and I love my
party, it's the country that has to come first.
Wow. What a powerful message of national unity
and togetherness from Chris Christie. Am I right?
No, no, no. I'm wrong. I'm that it's not that at
all. They are now dropping like flies simply to
preserve their own political futures. They're not
rational or sensible. Now they are abandoning the
sinking Trump ship before it's too late. If they
believed that continuing to push this was in their
interests, they would keep saying it was stolen
by Joe Biden. They care about themselves, period.
They see the writing on the wall. These are
terrible people. And this is now so absurd that
some of them are starting to bail out. Chris
Christie has been one of the most pathetic
Trump Brown nosers for the last four years. And
now we're supposed to pretend he's one of the good
guys. Give me a break. This is just like when you
occasionally hear something mildly sensible on Fox
News, it's still Fox News. Chris Christie stood
behind Donald Trump, literally and figuratively,
for four years. No matter what Donald Trump
did, Trump's lack of taking the virus seriously
is arguably part of how Chris Christie himself
ended up not only infected with the virus, but
in the hospital for a week or longer. And then he
still votes for Trump. And his reaction after the
election was, hey, guys, let's show respect to the
70 million people that voted for Trump. And now he
says, oh, it's become a national embarrassment.
OK, thanks, Chris. He's getting some distance
from Trump so that it helps his political future.
That's all that this is. It's fun to watch. It is
interesting to the degree that it triggers Donald
Trump, but that's all. And in fact, it's almost
ironic to hear Chris Christie say Trump's legal
team is the national embarrassment when Christie
himself has been a national embarrassment for a
very long time. And his Pathet I mean, remember
Trump, much like Trump, a disgustingly attacked
Ted Cruz saying his wife is ugly and went after
Rand Paul and all these guys fell in line.
Trump did the same thing to Chris Christie.
And Chris Christie ended up there the day after
dropping out of the Republican primary in 2016.
Standing behind Donald Trump completely falling
in line. Chris Christie was part of creating
this national embarrassment and is complicit in
it. And he should have to apologize for that. Now,
simply saying, oh, this is starting to be
embarrassing. It's too little, too late,
Chris. And if Chris Christie came out and said,
guys, I've been complicit in this, I'm sorry,
the entire presidency was a disaster, I don't
know what happened to me, but I throw myself at
your mercy in order to to to be forgiven for what
I did. I would find myself a little more moved by
it if that was the case. This I'm not falling
for this. This this is B.S. and this is the
the rats are leaving the sinking ship, trying
to trying to preserve their own future political
lives. And it's pathetic. And Chris Christie
is right. But it's too little, too late.